our brain takes information from the
sensory environment via several sensory
organs and process that information to
give rise to behaviors now during this
process neurons of our brain communicate
with each other by a electrical signal
that we call as action potential so in
this video I would talk about action
potential and describe what exactly is
action potential in a simplistic manner
so this video is a overview of that I
have another video which describes the
details of the action potential so
simply action potential means change in
voltage over time in response to a
sensory stimulus for example change in
voltage in the neurons of our eyes in
response to a visual stimulus so action
potential is the change in voltage from
the resting membrane potential to the
reversal potential of sodium in simple
words a change in voltage from minus 70
millivolts to plus 30 millivolts that
means a delta change of voltage about
100 millivolts is the action potential
now the action potential is a
all-or-none phenomenon that means either
there is an action potential firing or
there is no action potential firing and
there is no chance of any intermediate
state so action potential could be
thought of a binary process and it
definitely like a binary situation like
zeros and 1 both have a coding value
firing action potential or not having an
action potential both of that have
important significance in terms of
neuronal coding that I would be
describing in other videos now
propagation of the action potential down
the axon could be thought similar to a
transverse wave propagation in case of
transverse wave the media particles do
SH em around its mean position and our
overall disturbance is propagate
along the length so simply in case of
action potential there are several
unique interchanges ionic influx and out
flux that ultimately leads to this
voltage disturbance to propagate along
the axon now along during the time of
action potential what are the major
ionic flows happens we will take a look
at it in couple of slides so at first
the most important events during action
potential propagation is sodium influx
and the potassium efflux so the sodium
and potassium current is the most
important constituent of the action
potential
now during depolarization phase there is
a huge amount of sodium influx and in
the repolarization flay phase there is
potassium out flux so what exactly
happens at this phase so let us look at
phase by phase so building at the at the
resting condition where there is no
disturbance that the potential of the
membrane sits around minus 70 millivolts
a disturbance or a stimulus coming in
the membrane potential started
increasing and when it reaches about
minus fifty five millivolt which is the
threshold for action potential firing
then huge amount of sodium channel opens
synchronized Li and there is a huge
sodium influx now sodium is a positively
charged ion and thereby the membrane
potential start increasing increasing
and increasing and reaches the reversal
potential of the sodium after a point of
time about a millisecond there is
opening of the potassium channel the
potassium channels opens in this range
and that is why there is a huge
potassium outflux happening just after
the sodium influx that again decreases
the membrane potential and brings it
closer to the resting membrane potential
so this is the ionic basis of
depolarization and the repolarization
phase of the action potential
now can we record action potential it
turns out there are several methods by
which we can record the action potential
one of the method that I have described
is patch clamp technique in this patch
clamp technique a portion of the
membrane is taken inside of a recording
pipette and a seal is established after
that using current injection we can
prove the new loan for its capability of
firing action potential and when we give
a current which has substantial amount
of depolarization capability or
otherwise known as depolarizing current
the neuron would start firing an action
potential for example here you can see
the neuron has started firing action
potential now the action potential that
is propagating down the axon would reach
the second neuron that is it is
connected to and would create graded
potential into the dendritic region and
this graded potential would be summed in
somewhere in the axonal initiation
segment and which might give rise to a
halt or non action potential so here I
want to draw your attention to these two
terms credit potential and action
potential greater potential is
completely different from action
potential action potentials magnitude
cannot be changed whereas the frequency
latency etc could be changed but the
graded potential its magnitude its
amplitude could be changing depending
upon the intensity of the stimulus so
graded potential action potential both
are different kinds and both has
important values in terms of coding so
we would be describing graded potential
in a separate video now the various
aspects of action potential firing is
important for example the firing
frequency the interspike interval that
means the time between two subsequent
action potentials the latency of action
potential the firing pattern or input
resistance etc all these parameters
associated with action potential
propagation is very important in
of sensory coding the way brain codes
information involves all these important
parameters and let me give you a very
example here is a neuron which can let's
say it can fire in a regular interval
like this it could also fire in a
delayed fashion with a subsequent
latency in this pattern do or it can
fire in a regular bursting regime so
depending upon all these three firing
pattern different message could be
processed inside the brain and indeed
their example in the sensory system for
example in case of olfaction
the concentration and the information
about the intensity of the order in the
environment is conveyed by the firing
pattern and the firing rate of the
olfactory receptor noodles so there by
several aspects of the action potential
is very important for sensory coding now
in other videos I would be talking about
how what is the basis of propagation of
action potential what are the detailed
mechanism by which action potential
propagates and why action potential
never decays like a graded potential and
in the end screen of this video you
would see there recording techniques by
which you can find action potential and
also about little bit about the gradient
potential now if you like my video give
it a quick thumbs up don't forget to
Like share and subscribe thank you for
listening